let's talk about how to get rid of
toenail fungus okay pretty
straightforward there's two main
ingredients to this formula but more
importantly we want to ask questions
like why do certain people get toenail
fungus yet other people never get it why
is it so common in diabetics in fact in
one study 77 out of 152 diabetics
had this condition why is it so common
with people with Cushing syndrome that's
a condition where you have high levels
of cortisol you're really stressed out
and why are you at risk for getting this
condition if you have your spleen
removed so these are all questions we
need to ask and the reason I'm doing
this video is I really want you to start
to change the way you look at your body
change the way you look at symptoms look
at symptoms as the indicator light on
your car your engine light right you
wouldn't just disconnect the wire right
you would try to find out and diagnose
what's really underneath
the hood unfortunately in medicine uh
they don't do that it's all about just
treating the symptom and with medication
that has side effects of course we want
to treat the symptom with natural things
but we also want to find the cause so
let's talk about this like why would
your body develop this white yellow uh
black crusty toenail that is breaking
off your nail bed I mean that's just
weird it's a condition where it's
resistant to medical treatment okay
either the topical treatment doesn't
work because it doesn't penetrate the
nail or the systemic treatment maybe
will work temporarily but it comes right
back and it gives you side effects in
the process just as a side note I talked
to someone recently who had some foot
pain and they go to the doctor and the
way they doctor treated it is to give
them
steroid not localized injected into the
foot but an oral steroid prednisone
which is going to be systemic it's going
to go through the entire body to get rid
of her foot pain my thought is like
what's going to happen a few days it's
going to wear off it's going to come
right back and then what you take
another one and then another one and
then all of a sudden all the problems
that come with it I mean it's just
it's just bizarre but with toenail
fungus just in America there's like 35
million people who have this and in the
western part of the world it's more of a
fungus in the tropical regions it's more
of a mold because it's more moisture and
it's more humid so how do we figure this
out well first thing is okay we have
this fungus right what is going on with
fungus in the nail well we can relate it
to other things where we have an
overgrowth of fungus or candida or a
yeast infection in other parts of her
body like whether it's the groin or even
the mouth or on your skin you see a lot
of people get an overgrowth of candida
or Yeast after an antibiotic because the
normal bacteria in their body keep this
fungus in check okay so there's always
this balance you know that you have
friendly bacteria in your gut and you
know you have friendly bacteria on your
skin but did you know you also have
friendly fungus on your skin as well and
in inside your body you have friendly
candida and you have friendly yeast it's
not just about bacteria the friendly
fungus is called microbiota microbiota
describes the different funguses that
live on and inside your body that can
help you unless the environment changes
they get stressed and some of them turn
pathogenic so a big part of this has to
do with this battle between your own
immune system which by the way
is your friendly microbes it's also your
friendly fungus that's part of your
immune system it's not a separate thing
and this is why when you lose your
immune system with like HIV for example
or you had your spleen removed
or you had this high level of cortisol
and Cushing syndrome what happens when
you have high cortisol you literally put
your immune system into a state of sleep
you paralyze your immune system so
cortisol is a steroid which basically
gets rid of inflammation and it gets rid
of symptoms from autoimmune diseases it
calms an over-reactive immune system
because it suppresses the white blood
cell well in the process it gets rid of
your defense mechanism against pathogens
so if you have this chronic elevation of
cortisol as in Cushing syndrome you're
more at risk for getting all sorts of
problems like toenail fungus like
autoimmune problems and in regard to
diabetes let's talk about that for a
second
what is diabetes it's a situation where
you have high levels of sugar what does
fungus yeast mold love to eat that's
sugar even in the soils with the plants
the plant actually gives that fungus
carbohydrates and then the fungus gives
the plant root minerals so it exchanges
a carbohydrate or minerals so fungus
love sugar and of course the cortisol
with the stress that's another thing in
fact there's one study that I read that
when a person started to balance out
their cortisol levels
tonal fungus went away which is
interesting and then what's unique about
the HIV is that that is a condition
where you basically lose your entire
immune system so all sorts of things can
happen anytime you want to strengthen
your immune system there's four things
to do number one start increasing your
vitamin D levels okay number two vitamin
C a natural form of vitamin C and then
three zinc
very important and number four fasting
okay start doing regular intermittent
fasting and periodic prolonged fasting
that will strengthen your immune system
so I just wanted to get that out I
wanted to talk about some of the things
that are underneath the hood of your
body so you can start to maybe work with
those things let's get right to the
remedy there's just two things to focus
primarily on number one is Epsom salts
and number two is iodine so with epsom
salts you just take two tablespoons mix
it with you know three or four cups of
water where it's really hot dissolve it
completely and then you're going to soak
your foot in that solution for about 15
minutes okay once a day and what's going
to happen it's going to start to kill
off the fungus the cool thing is you
won't develop resistant to it like
medication then it won't give you any
side effects okay so that's number one
and number two you'll just take a drop
of iodine and the type of iodine I'm
going to recommend is either decolorized
iodine okay so it doesn't leave a yellow
stain or the pobedome iodine just one or
two drops right on the toenail and let
that seep in let it dry and do that
before you go to bed and that will
actually penetrate because you just
soften the nail from the Epsom salts so
right after that you put the drop on Let
It soak in and iodine is a potent
antimicrobial okay without the side
effects so those are the two things to
do but there's other things you can also
add that can help tea tree oil is
anti-fungal
oregano oil is anti-fungal clove oil is
anti-fungal and lavender the essential
oil is a very potent
anti-microbial and anti-fungal lavender
smells beautiful but microbes hate it so
you could add really any one of those to
help speed the process up if you wanted
now since we're on the topic of Remedies
there's a really interesting video that
sort of relates this video but it's a
little different it's how to get rid of
skin tags you should check that one out
right here